foreign
[Music]
that's a lot of guys
it looks really mean
those things I think it's those guys who
work in Times Square you know the
mascots yeah the gecko geckos more like
little Shreks to me it's just fine
we've prepared our whole lives for this
I've actually been in a fight before and
I don't know if you've noticed but all
I've got is a big stick how did I end up
with a baby I confused this situate
laughter you're not funny enough for
that dude talk
a strange problems that's not a problem
oh my God oh my God
[Music]
guys
maybe they'll see the humanity at our
tragic backstory
[Music]
I got it
thank you
I got a big stick
s
sorry sorry
[Music]
no problem
[Applause]
[Music]
guys look around
[Applause]
[Music]